dans les cantines personne n'agit et
c'est vrai que c'est en train de monter
grandement les parents se demandent
vraiment moi je suis pour le maintien de
la couverture des écoles c'est vrai mais
là les parents sont en train de se dire
est ce que je dois laisser mon enfant à
licola glières chrono français dans un
collège parisien on n'arrivait pas
décaissés c'est vrai tout ce que dit ce
qu'il ya des quatre positifs qui sont
cachés dans les collèges à mais depuis
septembre mois c'est n'importe quoi
monsieur blanc car mon à longueur de
temps il a santé publique france vous
connaissez tous est un organisme public
c'est pas du tout une officine d'islamo
gauche histoire voilà quoi dit il 10 8 à
9 % de cas chez les élèves
la caution bancaire 0,3 très étonnant et
la scène il continue dans les
établissements scolaires on a 40 cm les
intérêts des propos n'engagent que
nicolas c'est lui qui voit là et les
salariés mais les mes collègues et les
stylos rouges que je représente
aujourd'hui aussi alors oui si l'on m'a
rappelé que c'est c'est un groupe
d'enseignants menée après pas de vague
en décembre 2018 qui luttent pour
salaire moyen respect notre devise pour
être entendue écoutée mieux payés mieux
considéré donc vous pensez que alors
vous pensez à prendre bien sûr ou
conditionnés pour cacher des cas de kobe
pour ne pas fermer les écoles à mais
complètement monsieur blanc caire ne
veut pas que les écoles ferment
nous ne voulons pas non plus depuis le
mois de juin nous demandons je demande
partout je clame je crie je pleure pas
trop je demande à ce que les
établissements soient nuit en 2000
groupe collèges lycées écoles primaires
pour empêcher la fermeture pour l'éviter
en gros que tout le monde prenne sa part
fasse sa part face son effort les
parents aussi et qu'ils acceptent de se
dire bah un jour sur deux peut-être pour
éviter la fermeture pour éviter que des
gens ne meurent pour éviter que l'on se
retrouve en réa je vais prendre je vais
faire un effort et ma petite réunion
zoom mais je peux la faire avec mon
enfant un jour sur deux à la maison
non non on n'a pas ça va barder j'allais
demander quelle explication il pouvait
trouver à ça je veux dire qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire dans ces cas là mais la
réalité que de nombreux parents ils ne
veulent pas ou ne peuvent pas s'occuper
des enfants toute la journée vous vous
avez dit veulent ils ne le veulent pas
beaucoup ne blesserait
s'il n'a pas des noms mais c'est très
calme très compliqué quand vous
travaillez arica si vous faites de vos
enfants ou est ce qu'ils vont manger on
parlait de cantine tout à l'heure c'est
très compliqué le diable à maurice alors
je sais que c'est pas la honte à tout le
monde
il suffit d'écouter ya huit jours sur
france info un cadre d'entreprise qui
expliqué qu'ils n'avaient pas envie
d'être au télétravail qui pourrait mais
qu'il répondit d'oublier les pardons
mais c'est un boulot et ce alors qu'il
reste des baisses chez lui vous êtes
isolé mais ça c'est un énorme problème
est la réalité lui laissons le terrain
donc ils voient bien des gens qui sont
parfois au chômage et qui emmène quand
même leurs enfants à l'école qui veut ne
pas garder l'enfant lui la voix la
réalité et mais aussi il faut pas dire
un jour sur deux il ya des gens c'est
pas possible un jeune sur deux ya des
gens qui travaillent cinq jours sur
certes elle même six jours sur sept et
même sept jours sur sept fois sur le
scandale de l'école moi je suis je suis
sûr à 100% j'ai des cars mois autour de
moi parce que j'ai autour de moi j'ai
des as mg des institutrices j'ai plein
de gens qu'est ce qu'ils me disent les
asem sont pas protégés l'industrie sont
pas protégés des messages sont venus
arroser les verts ce qu on ferme à vous
classe sur 18
alors évidemment l'école n'est pas
fermée mais quand vous avez 12 classes
qui sont fermés sur 18 s'est quasi
l'école qui est fermé
monsieur blanc caire qui avait dit le 6
novembre 2020 on va faire des tests
salivaires dans toutes les écoles je me
suis renseigné du côté de vernon dans
l'ue27 je suis me renseigner du côté
denis dans le 95 colomb de turin
argenteuil je trace je me suis renseigné
le guet devant six ont six ou sept
écoles yao kraft est ce qui est fait et
les enfants et les et les asem et les
instits et les animateurs ne sont pas
testés
c'est évidemment leur intérêt c'est de
cacher n'est qu'à parce que si tu
révèles l'écart moment donné va falloir
fermer les écoles